there's a lot going on uh right now but
the idea we're going to be able to
you know click a switch
bring down the cost of gasoline
is not likely in the near term nor is it
with regard to food
well president biden clearly has no idea
on how to solve the inflation crisis and
it seems like the white house can't stop
contradicting him on what he knows about
the big issues facing americans as
millions struggle to find baby formula
on shelves biden revealing he was not
aware of the crisis until april despite
previous claims from white house
officials that they had been working on
the issue for months
well
here's the deal
i became aware of this problem
sometime in
after april and uh in early april about
how intense it was
so jessica the the timeline they said
they started working out in february
yesterday the president says he just
basically found out about it that
they're trying to solve the problem
it is feasible
that there were people working on it and
the fda was obviously involved in this
because they were the ones that
triggered the whole recall
in the first place but the none of these
answers are okay and the judge and i
were talking about this um yesterday as
a mom and a new grandmother that the
meeting of the ceos of the formula
companies yesterday was the most
infuriating thing i've ever seen where
they all admitted that they knew that
this was going to happen when the avid
recall was coming down the pike
and when your product and i understand
everyone you know we're good capitalists
who just want to make money your product
serves a really important purpose right
like this isn't bedazzled keychains this
is keeping kids alive there is no other
option for children
than to be on formula in many cases and
i don't want to hear on my twitter about
i should just start breastfeeding again
that's not happening here you're not on
twitter that's basically what a lot of
people would hope would happen i am on
twitter it is ugly out there but i am on
twitter i think you even follow me
anyway it it's it's really bad and for
many people and moms especially this is
equal to the gas crisis because and it's
every day i cannot get in a car i cannot
avoid going home and feeding my kids i
think it's worse than it is
it is worse because it's a lifeline and
by the way some women don't lactate what
about all the men i don't lactate they
they don't lactate look yeah
here's the bottom line when you've got a
company like adam abbott i should say
and there are so few companies that
actually make baby food in america for
them and you can't figure out that
there's going to be a drought in baby
formula then you're just stupid and for
you not to give any kind of confidence
or hope to the american people and say i
only learned about this in april when
they complained the whistleblower in
october you didn't get your button gear
until december you made an appointment
in january didn't make a decision until
february all of them are so slow and so
behind uh in terms of what they do
there's no initiative there's no caring
there and what they have done and this
administration just lies about oh we
didn't know what happened the press
secretary here i don't know if i feel
sorry for her or what but she doesn't
know what the president knows
yeah jesse it's a definitely a
reflection of clunky bureaucracy
and the fda especially not foreseeing
this crisis when they decided to shut
down the plan well katie remember they
couldn't interview the whistleblower for
several weeks because the
whistleblower's schedule was too jammed
all right so biden was made aware of
this in april then why did he wait until
i don't know last week to start flying
formula from europe why did he wait
until a couple weeks ago to invoke the
defense production act he said what the
timeline is so the next question is mr
president why did you wait a month and
have to do anything about it he didn't
answer that question
i went
formula shopping today emma said pick up
some jugs so i went to walgreens and she
said get as much as you can so i went
and there's nothing on the shelf
there are no jugs the stuff i get yeah
for my baby right so there was four jugs
and i think to myself what do you mean
what is jessie's
jug it's just a regular bottle i don't
know why he's calling it a big jug what
should i call it
okay so there's four and i said to
myself should i hoard no should i get
all four don't i only got two and then i
came back and then goes you only got two
and then she went out and got the next
two so now they have nothing left greg
it's a perfect uh example of how the
administration works like they say we've
been working on this since february and
look at the results we've been doing so
well even though the result is a
complete disaster here is the good news
because joe biden said he didn't see he
doesn't see the food prices going down
in the near future so he didn't see
afghanistan uh pull out disaster he
didn't see the baby formula disaster the
crime wave so if he says he doesn't see
the prices going down they're gonna go
down
because he's always wrong murphy's law
he's always wrong and the other upside
to this is that you know i think the
ineptitude is educating millions of
people on the fruitlessness of
virtue signaling and progressive
identity politics because you got to
remind yourself that nearly all the
major problems
that went ignored was because
they listened to the left who had placed
their twitter shaped concerns in front
of real concern so it wasn't about
inflation or crime or the border it was
about trans in the military debt
cancellation uh pronouns statues school
names that became the face of the party
and this is why our show's so popular is
because we're talking about the real
stuff and people are learning like how
did we get sold this bill of goods on
these other channels that we're talking
about important things like statues
coming down if we spent less time
pulling down statues and more time
taking care of our children oh
wait we wouldn't be in this situation
that's beautiful and that's all i got to
say i went to brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now